well the romanian government has
announced strict new anti-cova 19 rules
as authorities battle a surge in cases
and deaths romania has one of the
highest death rates from the disease in
the world measures include a nighttime
curfew and closing schools doctors have
launched an emergency vaccination drive
it's been a desperate week in romanian
hospitals as patient numbers surge
new infections are rising by about 15
000 a day with nearly 400 deaths
intensive care beds are increasingly
unavailable one bucharest clinic has run
out of space to store the dead
all the stories on tv are about morgues
filled with dead people and relatives
crying outside
the drastic situation in hospitals has
sparked a dramatic uptake in
vaccinations
a huge vaccine drive is underway a
record 86 000 got the jab in a single
day
i really don't know why i decided so
late to get vaccinated
people started to rush to get vaccinated
even though most of them are only coming
in because of the restrictions
romania's vaccination rates are still
among the lowest in the european union
with just over a third of adults fully
protected covered 19 rules are being
tightened
as of monday the mask becomes mandatory
everywhere inside or outside
those unvaccinated will have plenty of
restrictions unfortunately
the restrictions will remain in place
for 30 days at first
romania is losing one person every five
minutes to covert 19.
it's a battle of life or death
many countries in eastern europe are
already dealing with overcrowded
hospitals because of the coronavirus new
infections and deaths in ukraine are the
highest they've been since the beginning
of the pandemic a low vaccination rate
means the population remains especially
vulnerable to severe infections and the
government has been forced to introduce
new restrictions on public life in
response
trying to console another gravely ill
patient
people suffering from covid's delta
variant have practically filled this
hospital west of kiev
doctors expect even more cases and they
know why
the severity of the course of the
disease is certainly higher and it's
more aggressive than last year
unfortunately the patients in our
department are not vaccinated
only 15 of ukrainians are fully
vaccinated against the coronavirus one
of europe's lowest rates
after experiencing the disease some
people here say they should have acted
differently
[Applause]
people need to get into their heads that
they need to take care of themselves and
get vaccinated because it's really scary
i didn't believe it either
[Music]
as new cases and deaths from the disease
reach new heights in ukraine more people
are getting their coronavirus shots but
not all have come voluntarily
since it's become compulsory we have no
choice otherwise we wouldn't
ukraine now requires many state
employees including teachers to be
vaccinated against the virus
and to ride public transport people now
have to be either vaccinated or tested
before traveling but again resentment
against the measures is widespread
it should be a person's choice to get
vaccinated
according to the constitution we have
the right to choose don't we so my
attitude is entirely negative
to get around the restrictions many
ukrainians have been buying fake
vaccination documents yet another
problem for a country already struggling
with the pandemic
you